[inaudible].
Okay,
so the rough patch,
why do they call it the rough patches there?
A rough patch in every marriage.
Simple answer.
Yes.
More than one.
Usually I named the book the Rough Patches,
which is obviously a very common term.
It's not only applied to what I'm writing about,
but um,
because what I was noticing in my practice as I see couples and individuals was
people having this sense that they had
created their life.
They had partners,
they had houses,
they had children,
they had a structure.
But that sometime in the middle period they were finding themselves feeling kind
of lost or confused or stuck or feeling that something about their emotional
life wasn't working.
So that's what I use.
Uh,
the term four.
But the book is structured so that each chapter is about a different kind of
rough patch or crisis or struggle.
So there's a chapter on money issues,
there's a chapter on an affairs,
there's a chapter on alcohol use,
different things that people confront over the course of a long relationship.
And so are these the types of topics that are covered in the book?
Are they,
are they changing over time?
Are they the same problems that our parents have dealt with and our grandparents
dealt with?
Or is there something different now?
Well,
I think people now live longer than our parents.
Our grandparents did.
So people are trying to have close relationships over longer lives.
And our model of marriage has also changed.
In other words,
that used to be more of an economic arrangement and the 60s,
it was more kind of find yourself arrangement.
Now it's more of a,
you know,
how can we have a close intimate partnership that helps carry us through and
support each other in that process.
And so the model has changed and our lifespan has changed.
So that's a fact of living today.
Um,
there obviously the timeworn problems that people have in relationships in terms
of emotional communication and the other things I've mentioned,
I think a couple things that probably all of you can relate to that are new and
different or the way in which technology is completely seeped into every aspect
of our lives.
Um,
and all the possibilities for connecting that have been created by social media.
And my understanding of that is it's new and old.
I mean,
it's a new way in which we deploy our time,
but it's also often used in very,
um,
common ways,
namely to disconnect,
to avoid difficult emotional situations,
to having a moment of escape and privacy.
I mean,
all the things that people are always trying to balance and marriage.
Anyway.
What about the trends in terms of when people are having children or,
um,
kind of some of the historical gender roles in relationships or those adding
complexities as well?
Right.
So a couple of things are really interesting about that.
One is that if you look at the statistics on longevity of marriage,
now the people who are staying married and not getting divorced are people who
have education and economic resources,
which makes a lot of sense because often they have fewer stresses in their
lives.
They have fewer economic stresses,
they have more opportunities.
It also usually means it's,
there's more egalitarian marriage.
And whereas in the past,
and this,
even this,
as recently as the sixties and seventies,
women's education was actually a risk factor for divorce.
Now it is a protective factor for marriage.
So in other words,
you can say that an egalitarian marriage tends to offer certain opportunities
for collaboration and partnership.
Of course,
it also means we're all taking all roles all the time,
right?
So everybody is trying to be a full partner in every way.
Work,
child care,
money,
household chores,
et cetera.
So that means a lot of collaboration,
a lot of negotiation,
a lot of conversation,
and often conflict around division of labor,
of fairness,
who does what,
that sort of thing.
And so talking about children,
how our children hard on a marriage,
right?
So children are known to be one of the hardest stresses on a marriage.
Obviously it's one of the reasons people get married.
It's one of the reasons people want to stay married.
Having a family as a high aspiration for many,
many people.
But,
but the research does.
Unequivocably suggests that when you have your first child,
your marital satisfaction goes down.
And the way I think about that,
because I teach a class to,
um,
young parent,
well,
not so young in the bay.
I live in the bay area and I teach a class for people who are about to have
their first child.
And it's basically how to keep the couple relationships strong when you have a
child.
And if this demographic may be similar to that one,
but people's big worry is I've had this great life,
I've,
you know,
done all the school stuff.
I'm a fully formed individual.
We have this great partnership.
Is this kid going to kind of ruin everything?
Right?
I mean that's a whole different model from when people had their kids that,
you know,
21,
22,
25,
whatever.
Um,
and so there is this feeling that,
you know,
children are going to disrupt my life often with,
with people today.
Um,
but the way,
the way I think they do disrupt your life.
Cause I think when all the grandchildren are wonderful but the,
that it depletes resources.
I mean that there's basically more people that everything has to go around.
So if you think of that purely,
certainly economically,
but also emotionally and timewise.
And so I think what happens with children often is that the to do list and the
hierarchy of things that have to happen,
you know,
your emotional needs and your need to connect those lower,
lower,
lower on the list.
Because of course they're much more important things to take care of.
And as a mature functioning adult you have to take care of the kids first,
the job second.
And so it's this sort of a subtle demotion that starts happening about the
relationship.
And I think people try really hard to work on that.
But what's so tricky about it is that the emotional relationship is something
that is complex,
is messy,
emotions are inconvenient.
You might feel things,
you might feel angry or sad or just connected and need to actually take time to
talk about that and sort it through.
And that's exactly what people are missing is the time to do it.
So that just takes,
takes its toll over time.
I imagine too that that things like sleep deprivation probably play into it,
at least in in my own personal experience.
Um,
and,
and things like wanting to have those conversations.
But maybe not in front of the children.
Yeah.
Right,
right,
right.
Less time alone.
Obviously I sleep deprivation is murder for your moods,
for your sense of resilience,
right.
All your worst qualities.
Totally on display.
So yeah,
all of that.
So then like a once a week,
date night,
I'll fix it.
All right.
Yeah,
of course.
Yeah.
Now one thing I do tell couples,
which sounds incredibly pragmatic,
but I think it really can help.
Part of the problem with date night,
which I write about in the book,
um,
is that,
what you want a date night is fun.
You Want Romance,
you want fun,
you want not to be worrying about the kids' problems all the time.
And that can be hard because if that's the hot top stress on your mind and your
only time to talk,
it's like,
well,
now's the time.
But I recommend the people decide on a time of the week,
like eight o'clock Tuesday morning.
That's not when you're about to try to go to sleep.
That's not when you're going to try to have sex.
It's not on your date night.
And it's like,
let's just take a minute to check in.
How's the division of Labor?
How are you feeling about our relationship?
Just sort of like almost like a meeting.
Um,
because it's what I find is so pernicious and couples over time,
because in this book is really about this thing,
which is that our emotional life is who we are and our relational life is who we
are.
And yet it sort of gets put on the sidelines,
right?
And so easily in terms of all our other roles.
And so I think that it's can be very hard to be the person who has to bring up
the conversation or has to be the person to say,
let's talk,
you know,
some people are like,
ah,
no,
I don't want to talk.
Right?
So if you know that it's Tuesday morning at eight that you're going to have this
back and forth,
it can take the pressure off of one person to be the initiator.
We're up discussion.
Or,
or when when your spouse hears,
hey,
we need to talk that they don't like to start having a panic attack.
It's bad.
Right.
Exactly.
They,
everybody knows eight o'clock,
Tuesday morning,
we're going to,
you know,
touch base.
So you talked about having more resources can actually contribute to better
outcomes.
Um,
so then how can money be such a,
such a problem if you have more money?
Isn't that better?
Okay.
It's certainly better than not having money,
right?
I mean,
um,
you know,
again,
on this sort of two Americas thing where people with education and economic
resources are doing better in terms of their marriage than people.
I mean,
that's sort of the rich get richer and the poor get poorer.
that's the America we live in,
right?
So people who are at the poorer and less educated,
um,
part of the demographic tend to not get married as much,
not stay married,
sent of more often,
et cetera.
And obviously economic stress is a huge difficult thing when you have it.
Um,
but you know,
just like everything else,
I mean,
it reminds me of the fact that people come in to couple therapy and they say,
I can't believe we're fighting about,
you know,
the toothpaste tube or who takes out the trash.
This is so trivial.
It's so stupid.
Like why are we fighting about these things?
But of course life is those things,
right?
And it's this constant navigation of those things.
And money is a really charged issue,
even if you've have a lot of it.
Because I believe the reason it's a charged issue is because it's so close to
our sort of primal sense of survival and identity.
I mean,
especially in this country perhaps,
but how you spend money,
what money you have,
where you're allocating it is very close to people's sense of who they are.
And so in a marriage,
you know,
the ideal picture of a marriage in my mind is there's one individual,
another individual,
and together you create this thing,
this living,
breathing organism called the marriage.
And so it's not just what do you want?
What do you want?
Oh,
if you get what you want,
I don't get what I want.
It's what is the marriage need?
What does the family need?
What do we need to gather to make this thing that we're creating together?
And I think money lends itself to a sort of zero sum mentality.
You know where people are kind of,
if you get yours I won't get mine.
And it breaks down very
quickly.
So
are you of the opinion then that all marriages can work,
all marriages can be made to be good marriages or are there situations where you
kind of need to know when to say when?
So when I started writing this book,
I had the hope,
I had the thought that um,
if people work enough on themselves,
they can work out their relationship because I felt in my,
in my work,
one of the things you run up against a lot of times when a couple's having
problems is they come in and each one wants you to fix their partner and make
them a better partner.
But it's very,
very hard for people to really take stock of themselves and think,
what am I contributing to this?
So part of the work of couple therapies,
you're both creating this,
you're both taking a role,
right?
So I sort of had this somewhat hopeful,
I guess,
idea that,
you know,
if people really grappled with their own stuff,
that they can come to the relationship.
I'm on a better footing and they can,
um,
we'll be in far better position to work it out,
all of which I still agree with.
But I do believe also that some marriages are in some sense fatally flawed.
And I think part of what the rough patch is about the book is about the thinking
is about is how do you figure that out.
Okay.
And so that,
that taking stock of yourself and,
and,
and personal accountability for improvement,
is that what you referred to in the book?
His guts?
That's an aspect of it.
You know,
I think people have the illusion that if the relationship's working well,
it's peaceful and serene.
And I don't think that,
I mean I've been married for 26 years and I would say every day we have some
kind of difficult conversation.
Not necessarily about a relationship each other,
but what about the one about the kids or what about some thing we have to solve?
And I think I talk about guts because they say it's always going to take courage
to have the difficult conversations.
I mean,
the fascinating thing about being a human,
and this is really come through with the attachment research and the last 30
years is we never get over being dependent and attached.
And so like,
you know,
I,
it's not okay that my husband and said I love you yesterday or last week or said
goodbye.
Then he has to keep doing it.
In other words,
you keep have to feeling that feeling that the person keeps turning toward you
and giving you appreciation and gratitude and affection and warmth,
right?
That's never done.
Right.
And so I sorta feel like similarly the hard conversations are never done if
you're trying to get through life,
if you're trying to figure out are we going to retire?
You know,
what's our budget like,
you know,
are we drinking too much?
Uh,
you know,
how's our sex?
Like all these things are not going to be easy to talk about.
They're actually,
uh,
vulnerable to talk about.
And I sort of want to help people shift their paradigm.
It's a good day for you.
So you have the guts to talk about the hard things.
And so you have a part in the book that you talk about where you say that that
you need to,
you get a life.
Can you explain?
Yeah.
So,
um,
the,
this book is,
is about,
you know,
how do you have a close relationship over a long life?
And I think sometimes people have that notion that,
um,
you know,
in order to get along with another person over a long time,
you sort of have such suppress yourself or somehow just adapt yourself.
And I really believe that it's only gonna work if you feel you can keep,
keep developing and growing as an individual that you bring more and more into
the partnership.
And I think sometimes people feel,
I was just talking to a friend yesterday was,
you know,
husband and does a doctor and he had all this training and the whole family life
was really geared around his,
his life and his profession.
And she said,
it's been so hard for me to sort of step out of that and realize I need to start
having,
you know,
a voice and assert what I want.
And we're always trying to balance that,
you know,
how much should we have to compromise?
How much do we have to suppress in order to get along?
But I really think over the long haul,
suppressing yourself isn't going to do the trick.
You have to be developing yourself and involving yourself in,
maybe that's going to mean saying,
look,
I'm changing and the way it was 10 or 20 years ago or five years ago isn't gonna
work for me.
I mean,
sometimes people get upset that they feel their spouses changed the contract on
them and we agreed under these circumstances and now how come you suddenly want
this?
And in mind you,
it's like,
of course that happens.
Time's passing,
you're growing,
you're changing.
And so,
you know,
my idea of get a license,
you have to sort of bring a lot of yourself to this and you have to keep
developing yourself.
And that can always be a kind of messy balancing APP.
And so the,
the,
the old adage about how marriages work,
um,
and it,
and it takes work to make a marriage.
Um,
you're,
you kind of challenge the idea of what work me in that,
in that describe distress.
So,
you know,
there is this idea of marriage is work and everybody rolls their eyes and it's
like,
ah,
and um,
I mean what I see is the work of marriage is being open and emotionally
vulnerable.
That's the work.
It's hard to show up every day and be honest and be say where you're at and
express your feelings and communicate about them.
And I happened to believe that it's not a tenable stance and a marriage to say,
I don't like to talk about feelings.
Basically.
Um,
you may not like to talk about feelings.
You may be a person finds it hard to talk about feelings.
It may be that you feel you're a person who's not an expert yet at talking about
your feelings.
But the,
the,
the job,
the work is to cultivate the ability to,
to know how you feel and to express it.
And that's not easy.
And every day you wake up and slapped you.
The easy thing to do would be to watch my shows and get on my phone and go and
work out and not really deal with this other complicated person who's like wants
things from Nan.
I want things rom and I can't really figure out how to get along with.
Right.
Your job is to go like,
no,
my job is to keep trying to turn toward this person.
Keep trying to figure out the relationship,
keep trying to be close.
That's not easy.
How do things like,
um,
communication differences and style and things?
Um,
you know,
uh,
one example being that,
um,
you know,
somebody may simply be wanting to talk about what they're thinking or feeling
and the other person thinks they're being asked to solve the problem.
Right?
And so when you,
when you are,
you know,
how do you overcome those kinds of things in that,
in that work to stay open?
Well.
So it's a complicated question,
but I'll just say one thing about it,
which is in I think chapter three or four of the book I,
I use this phrase called feeling with and thinking about,
and it comes out of a whole tradition of psychological research that you can
read more about if you're interested.
But basically we've all had that experience of being in a couple situation and
one person coming home,
it's just trying to pour out their feelings and talk about what happened and
sort of process that emotion.
The other one's saying,
well,
let me,
you know,
roll up my sleeves and help you solve the problem.
And then the first person,
I was like,
I don't want you to sell them my problem.
They just want you to listen to me.
Right?
So I believe that in a loving relationship,
if you look at emotional communication,
it has two parts.
It has you feel with the person and you think about the person.
And so you both have the experience of saying,
Oh,
I'm listening to you.
I'm trying to understand how you feel.
I'm trying to sort of empathize with you or you know,
you had a horrible day and I'm trying to like listen and support you and then
there's,
you know,
let me think about you.
Let me think about the problem.
Let me help you solve it.
Do you want to help solve it?
And sometimes couples breakdown,
you know,
sometimes it's a long gender lines,
sometimes the roles are reversed.
But basically it's like one person's fixing and the other person's just wanting
empathy,
right?
So I think everyone should be cultivating the ability to both feel with and
think about.
And love is expressed through that combination.
So if you could give everyone like one thing to either go back and think about
or practice at home tonight,
what would that first step?
Okay.
So
I think there's two things that are kind of in my mind,
like the wonder drug of marriage.
Like basically you can take two relationships that are identical in all their
different problems and assumptions.
But if in one situation the partners are able to say,
I'm aware of my part in this and I'm,
I'm trying to change.
So in other words,
what I call it,
and the book has self awareness and self responsibility.
So what I mean by that is if you can look at what you're doing together and
really say,
I know I have a part in this,
I'm trying to understand what I'm doing and I don't,
you know,
and I'm sorry if it bothers you or whatever and I'm trying to change that is the
key element.
Everything else can be equal.
But if people can do that,
if they can look at themselves and take account of their behavior and they'd be
responsible about it,
no matter what they're doing,
you know,
that is just the critical difference that gives people hope or hopelessness.
If you're married to a person where the story always is,
it's your fault that I'm doing this.
If you would just change,
I would be different.
That creates a very corrosive,
toxic,
hopeless atmosphere.
So that's the one thing I would say.
Okay,
you have your marching orders.
We are going to take questions because we are recording this.
Please make sure that you make your way to the microphone.
If you would like to ask questions today,
um,
I'll,
I'll talk about one more thing here and then we'll,
we'll go ahead and take questions from the mic.
So I keep waiting for the age of my children to arrive where it gets easier and,
uh,
yeah.
Okay.
And,
and what I get is this kind of reaction,
especially from people whose kids are older,
they're like,
no,
it's not easier.
It's just different.
And so navigating those changes over the years,
I have,
the communication's got to evolve too.
It reminds me of when you have really little kids who are like,
someday this will be over,
they'll be in school.
Right?
And then like,
you know what,
I thought my kids are 25,
21 and 19 and,
and every day we're worrying about something.
Right.
And,
and,
and every day we're having the hard conversations about what should we do about
x,
Y or z.
So it doesn't ever go away,
but there's a bread suffocation in actually being able to talk in a productive
and collaborative way.
That's kind of the hope.
Right?
So,
um,
yeah,
the physical exhaustion,
I would say changes,
but there's always something the state suddenly get higher.
Now we're worrying about can they support themselves and will they find
happiness and love and,
or we're worrying about our parents and the decline that happens there,
right?
So you kind of get out of one situation and you start to take on another and
that shift.
And one thing I say,
because I have a chapter on the empty nest,
which I've just become one of,
and um,
I say,
you know,
it's okay to be a beginner.
You know,
when you have first have a child,
you're a beginner.
When you first have no kids at home,
Like,
what do we want know?
Who are we?
What are we doing?
You know,
I think sometimes we feel by that age we should know what's going on.
And I think life's not like that.
You're always,
you're always learning.
Are there any additional considerations or,
or um,
tips for when you go through really big life changes,
whether it's a change in career or you're moving to a completely different place
or you've lost a parent,
like the big,
big life changes,
um,
where uh,
one of one or the other partner may not be kind of on their best.
Yeah.
Right.
So what other things can,
can people throw in to kind of help through those patches?
I think there's a couple things.
I think one is to keep reaching out toward each other,
but to respect what the other person needs.
And that can be hard sometimes because sometimes if you've got your partner's
gone through something,
they're very absorbed and they're not that available to you and you feel kind of
deprived.
Right?
But part of the thing is to keep offering support.
Um,
the other is to,
to sort of accept that.
I mean,
the point is,
I talk about the west with a metaphor,
the golden ring,
but the point is that you're standing next to each other looking at life and
trying to help each other through.
Right.
And they're going to be these things.
And so how,
you know,
to be able to just accept that they're going to be times when you're not
available to each other when one of you who's terribly sad when,
you know,
and,
and to sort of understand that that's kind of part of part of the deal.
Um,
but I do want to say,
and I talk about this and I have a chapter called love sickness and longing
about people who sort of have these very absorbing crushes,
you know,
even if they're happily married,
but they become,
and one of the things I've noticed about that in my own clinical work,
it's anecdotal,
but I'm really interested in studying it further,
is I think when people go through a big loss of some kind,
maybe lost a parent,
maybe lost a job,
maybe their child has it been problem,
it depletes them and sort of hollows them out.
And sometimes then they look,
they try to grab something in the world that will get them,
that will distract them.
And so I think also just to know your own vulnerability and the vulnerability of
your partner when you're going through something very devastating.
Hi.
Do you have any advice or thoughts on being in a relationship with someone who
has either a significantly less or orders of magnitude more income and wealth?
And I'm asking for a friend.
I suspect there'll be a lot of that.
Wow.
That is so interesting.
I mean,
in my own experience,
you know,
you realize that an adult life you often end up around people about your level
of wealth because it's not uncomfortable.
You sort of know what everybody can do.
Um,
but my best friend high school is extremely wealthy and so that's sort of my
only real,
it's,
it's fascinating.
I haven't given much thought to that.
I mean,
can you say anything?
Anything else specific about the struggle or the difficulty there?
Do you want me to make it up?
I'm gonna go sit down there.
Okay.
So one thing I could imagine coming up,
which comes up with my friend is,
you know,
she's like,
Hey,
let's have a spa weekend.
Well,
why can't afford the spa weekend?
Right?
So it's like you paying and you know then in a couple,
I would imagine there's sort of like what are the feelings around one person
having all this money that they can sort of funds thing.
They can't the equitable right now what I do with my friend is she gets this
huge,
you know,
spa weekend,
then I'd buy the like pizza on the way to the spa.
So I guess there's gotta be some discussion.
I mean money is,
is is obviously a huge hot button issue and there's a whole 50 big chapter on
it,
but,
but you know,
there's starting to be some discussion of what the understanding is there.
I think because I think this stuff's so complicated to talk about.
We're all so bad at talking about money that I think the main advice I would
have is like make it an explicit conversation.
Now that doesn't mean everybody's going to know what their feelings are because
it's an incredibly confused area for people and very conflicted and they're
complicated.
But at least to be having these sort of conscious,
explicit conversations of like,
you have this,
I have that.
How are we going to do this?
So everyone feels fair.
I'll just say one other thing.
I think one of the very most important things in a longterm relationship is a
sense of fairness and justice.
And if people start feeling that's not working,
it's very corrosive to the bond.
So I think you have to try to understand what does the money mean to each
person?
What to what extent do they feel you're kind of freeloading like even if they
don't want to feel that they kind of do like try to really get all of this stuff
out on the table so you can be kind of,
um,
conscious about the agreements that you're making.
I think that would be really useful.
Would you happen to have any advice for choosing a partner in the first place?
So death when it prompts you appear,
they're easier to work through?
Great question.
I mean,
I feel like my next book because my kids are kind of getting to that age is
like,
you know how to choose a good part,
where's my kids don't want to hear from me about it.
Right.
But um,
you know,
I would say the most important thing,
I don't think it's shared interests.
You know,
cause I actually you can bring a lot of different interests and it's important
to have your own interests anyway.
I think sometimes people think,
well we've checked all the boxes on all these compatibility things and I think
that's beside the point actually.
I think it's about emotional communication.
I mean obviously it's about the obvious thing is attraction and that you find
them fun and like being around them whatever a good,
if there's not a ton of mental illness in their family,
just on a purely genetic level.
But I would say that,
um,
it's about whether this person is able to talk through problems and,
and I wouldn't get married till you've had some opportunities to talk through
problems.
Weddings are great opportunities to talk through problems.
Just be willing to like bag if he can't get through the tolls.
But,
um,
but I think,
you know,
sometimes people got together with um,
highly emotional dramatic,
uh,
people who sort of excite them and activate them only to find out later the
person is a total piece of work,
can't regulate their emotions to save their life and it's driving them
completely nuts.
So I would try to,
uh,
really look at can this person manage their emotions and talk to me in any sort
of reasonable way about,
you know,
what they feel and can I do the same?
So volatility I think is something to avoid addictions or something today I
could go on and on,
but that would be my main advice.
So if you have a couple where both parties have a tremendous mountain common and
just do like everything together,
but then later on they realized that they do need to get a life and sort of like
cultivate themselves.
What do you think a good framework for that discussion would be?
You know,
how,
how would the couple find the ways in which they can and should develop
themselves and individual ways.
So That's interesting.
Um,
I mean I'm,
I'm getting a feeling that that question might have within it something like one
of the people is feeling a little bit of a need for more of that because if both
people are feeling like we just love doing everything together and have only
shared interests,
I can't really say that's a problem.
Right?
I mean life will introduce difference over time.
It just will,
you might have different parenting styles.
You might have different things you'd like to do with the kids.
You might have different families and different places that you're visiting.
I mean it will introduce it,
but say you're in the early courtship,
you've been together a while and you just love doing everything together.
That sounds great.
I think it's probably more though when one person is realizing it's a little
foster phobic here,
it's a little too much like this.
I need to have more outside.
And I think people in certain relationships feel very threatened by
individuality.
And I think that's something to really take on.
I don't think it's a tenable position in a long term.
Couple of you,
like you can't go out with your friends or you know,
you can't go be,
I mean that's a problem.
I think everybody,
it's important to hold a space for something like,
you know,
I love doing everything together.
We're incredibly compatible,
but sometimes I feel I just want to get out and do stuff with so and so or go do
this.
And I want that to be okay with us.
I don't want it to feel unsafe.
I don't want it to feel insecure.
I don't want you to be too anxious.
And anxiety is a huge thing in relationships and part of relationships is
working through why you're anxious.
What can I do to make you less anxious?
But claustrophobia and having to always be together is usually,
um,
over the long haul of problems.
If I were the person who was feeling like,
I just want a little more elbow room here,
I would just try to introduce it as,
you know,
um,
I think it'd be really healthy for our relationship.
Hey,
let's read this book.
It says it would be healthy for a relationship to have a few things that we do
alone just to have more interest in more.
I mean,
because as life goes on,
I see couples who are in the middle of life and they're like,
our life's really boring and under stimulating cause I feel like my spouse
doesn't have any interests or they're always sort of watching TV or whatever.
So it's just sort of talk about it in terms of the benefit to the relationship
of bringing more stuff in I think might help.
Hi.
I was wondering if you could speak to,
um,
living together before marriage a little bit.
Uh,
I'm in this situation where a lot of my friends and people I know who are in
their mid twenties out in Seattle,
they see you living together before marriage as a good trial period to see what
it's going to be like to be with this person for the rest of your life.
But then on the other side,
I have my parents and people their age who say,
no,
you can't do that because living together without a bigger sense of commitment
just makes it too easy to kind of run away at the earliest sign of trouble.
So I was wondering what your thoughts were on that.
That's
yeah,
that's a great question.
And I think there were search on that.
It's kind of all over the map,
so I'm just going to talk kind of from my own that kind of about this.
I think that um,
you know,
living together will confront you with,
um,
the problems of living.
Like someone say like,
just,
you know,
you'll have to work stuff out and that can actually help you figure out can we
work stuff out?
Right.
So that's on the plus side.
I think that,
um,
on the negative side is I now at my age,
I'm looking back because you know,
some of my friends are divorced,
some are,
it does seem to me that people kind of have backed into relationships who
weren't really wild about this person who made,
need,
sell persuaded by the other personnel.
Let's live together.
We're not really marrying,
it's just a step to work.
You know,
if in your heart you don't feel like I really want to be in this to live
together,
to see if you might then be more in love,
I think is a bad plan because once you're lives are merged and then we bought
furniture together and we have a dog,
it's so hard to ever really see things clearly and say,
well I got into this in a sort of halfhearted way and now how am I kind of
possibly get out?
So I think it takes a real reckoning with yourself.
Like,
I,
you know,
am I in love with this person?
Like,
do I really want to be with this person?
They may want to be with me more than I want to be with them.
I got to be truthful about that now because it's going to be way harder to get
out of it and five years.
So I think the parents are thinking that way.
They're sort of,
I mean,
you know,
whether you have a marriage contract,
I'm a licensed like in my mind kind of who cares?
But if your emotional feeling is not that this is really like the one,
I think it's very,
it can be very costly and more costly to women just in terms of biological clock
frankly.
So I mean I would be more my daughter.
I would be more worried about moving in with someone that my son probably.
Um,
couples strive for
happiness or contentment as individuals.
I was kind of vague,
so I don't know if that's really a distinction or is just semantics.
What do you think?
Well,
so wait,
when you say as individuals,
I'm,
I'm happy,
I'm content,
he's happy.
She's content.
We're good.
Yeah.
Is there,
is there a distinction there?
Is there like,
no,
you mean like if we're,
if we're content with each other,
is that enough?
Yeah.
Or like,
yeah.
Contend with our relationship or family or just a happy thought there.
Yeah.
Well,
right.
So this is so fascinating,
right?
Because we live in this culture where there's so much written about being happy,
And they're sort of the standard,
like,
you know,
are you happy and then you feel like you're falling short if you just actually
have a like,
calm,
happy,
you know,
look pleasant,
sane life.
Um,
you know,
again,
I don't want to say it's similar to my answer to the other person.
Uh,
in terms of do you feel something's missing?
Right.
I mean,
in some subjective sense.
I think some people are just much calmer,
much happier in a domestic or you know,
much more contented and a domestic arrangement where they get along and they
appreciate that and they,
they feel satisfied with that.
And other people need a lot of like,
excitement.
Right.
And it's sort of knowing yourself seems to be the important thing in terms of,
you know,
what do I need?
In my life.
I have a friend,
his son just got married very young and basically they both just love nesting.
Like that's who they are.
They like a home,
they liked being home together and they like,
you know,
buying little rugs and coaches and that's who they are.
Other people it'd be like,
oh,
I couldn't stand that.
I need to,
you know,
hike Mount Everest or whatever.
I mean,
so it really kind of depends too on sort of how you're made and how you're made
together.
Hi.
So,
um,
while people are dating like me and my friends like to say comments on,
you know,
hold their day and say,
oh,
they're totally for you all like,
no,
that no guy like you should totally date somebody else.
But once they're Mary Swerve Joan have that cop conversation maybe because you
know,
as opposed to all four of her whole out silence because we didn't say anything
then.
Um,
do you think that is okay?
Like,
is that beneficial to just now that they're married,
just let them be or if you do notice something that you know,
I'll be okay with them talking about that spells behind the lock.
Yeah.
Just wait.
So are you saying,
should you say something to the friend about her spouse or should the friends
say something to you about?
Yeah.
Should we as friends have a conversation at all?
All the people's spots.
Right.
So this is really interesting.
So I,
I'm at the view that if you have a close and you really have questions about who
they're with,
that you should talk to them about it.
Um,
so we're talking before the American,
right before they make that decision.
I believe that because I think,
mmm,
who else is necessarily going to say it?
And you know them and you may see something they don't see.
And in fact,
I just read a book that's sort of about people who've been married for a very
long time and sort of what advice they give for younger people.
And one of the things they say is if your friends or family or expressing doubts
about your partner,
listen to them.
And the idea there is that you may have,
you know,
because you're in law or whatever you have,
you don't have as clear pictures.
They do.
And so the people you trust,
you should listen to you.
And I thought that was really good advice.
Um,
but I do think,
I mean,
and I talk about this in my class with,
um,
you know,
these couples who are having their first baby,
part of the issue when you make a family and the little unit of the,
the couple and the child is you have to create a certain boundary around that.
You know,
you have to be,
have a filter for the inlaws and everybody else weighing in.
Right.
And I do think it's probably
risky to a marriage to feel like you have a closer channel with your
girlfriends,
then your spouse.
Um,
just in terms of that family structure and building something,
you know,
it can be a problem unto itself if every time you are having a fight with your
husband and you're telling your best girlfriend about it,
like that doesn't create trust with your husband.
But I think it's a really tricky thing to navigate that shift.
Right?
I mean basically it seems to me when your friend says we've decided to get
married,
I would sorta think it's time to just stop weighing in.
But I would be inclined to also not to then,
uh,
continue to have the same kind of girlfriend relationship about every complaint
she has about them.
I'd be Kinda like,
um,
I,
I just think that's a dividing line in my mind.
One of your earlier comments around,
you know,
if there's that one thing we take away and it was basically like self awareness
was the thing that kind of sets a relationships apart.
And I guess my question is,
um,
what happens when one partner brings something up and the other person doesn't
acknowledge it as a problem?
So I have two specific examples.
So on,
I don't know if you've ever heard there's like a New Yorker or Harper's article
on like emotional labor about how like,
um,
not to stereotype,
but like a lot of women take on a lot of like planning for the family or like
doing certain little things or things that,
you know,
cleaning up a little bit.
And then a lot of times their spouses don't consider those important,
so they don't consider it something they need to do.
Um,
and another example,
I have some friends that are having issues with their inlaws,
right?
So like they have different opinions and they look to their husbands for support
and they don't get it because the husbands don't see it as a problem.
So I guess,
you know,
self awareness is there,
but they have,
you know,
how do you address if they don't even see something as an issue?
No,
it's huge.
Those are both really,
really common things and really important things and not easy obviously.
MMM.
So I think I want to try to answer it from two angles.
These are deeply emotional issues that,
um,
you know,
division of labor and in loss.
MMM.
Sometimes when we don't see eye to eye on them,
we try to just manage our own feelings,
maybe suppress them,
not voice them,
you know,
work around at whatever.
But we come to a point where we feel so challenged by it that we might,
uh,
express it in a very strong,
maybe negative way,
at which point the partner is reacting purely to the negativity and just then
minimizes,
basically I see the partner and like just trying to survive emotionally sort of
like tries to shut you down because it's like,
oh,
that's not a problem.
That's not a problem.
Which is basically like,
I don't want to feel all the awful feelings that talking about this is created
and then that person shuts down and then the other person starts getting more
reactive and more upset.
So I just want to differentiate the actual problem,
which are real problems that need solutions from the process that gets going
when you can't find common ground and you just feel like you keep butting up
against the wall.
And what I'd like to suggest is that,
especially in these very emotionally loaded issues,
you,
um,
feel unapologetic for your stance and your emotions,
namely in these cases,
like it actually isn't unfair division of emotional labor or,
uh,
we're a family unit now and we need to fail.
You're out of functional way for us to stand up to the inlaws,
the,
you know,
those are legitimate issues that a person has every right to demand a solution
to and to,
to keep that in mind enough to say,
this is like,
this is an issue that we need to have a as neutral as possible a discussion on.
In other words,
it's not all about my reactivity to you,
it's about this isn't fair or this isn't working.
And then to go from that because really what happens often is when we're highly
emotional,
the other person shuts down because the reacting toward emotion.
So I feel like you have to keep advocating,
keep bringing it to the table,
not be willing to be shut down by,
Oh,
this is just you being emotional or you have a special problem with my mother.
But just keep being that the rational fair minded person that you are at work to
to solve this problem.
And I think people don't always think of it that way because it seems so kind of
denuded of the emotion.
But I think that's actually,
I mean Gottman again from Washington talks about new truck being as neutral as
possible in talking about highly emotional issues is key.
And I think what happens sometimes in these situations is people are trying to
emotionally survived so they start blaming other person for how they feel and
and minimizing,
right?
And what's so hard and challenging in that moment is to say,
I'm going to hold on,
I'm going to hold on to my point of view.
I'm can continue to assert it in a calm way and I'm not going to give up on this
until we come to a workable solution.
That takes fortitude,
it takes courage,
it takes energy,
it takes all sorts of stuff.
But that's the basic stance I think is important.
And I also think I said this,
but I'm just going to say it again.
I don't believe it's a tenable position.
In a longterm marriage to say,
I don't want to talk about it.
You have to learn how to talk about things and it's not okay for the person
saying,
why are you always harping on this?
You know,
I do plenty around here,
or whatever it is.
That's not going to be the end of that conversation.
It just,
you know,
you have to say no,
it's a problem from me.
One thing I talk about in my class with the parents of,
you know,
babies to be is your,
the grownups.
Now there's no parent out there deciding what's right and wrong and which
sibling is right.
You know when you're a kid it's like you started it.
No,
you started,
oh,
I don't care who started it.
You go to your room,
you are not,
people can sometimes have these sort of sibling ass kind of ideas about their,
some right or wrong on hide.
It could be handed down.
All of the marriage is about,
is caring about each other and caring about each other's feelings.
So if someone's minimize your feeling saying,
well I didn't feel that way,
so it's not real.
That's not a stance that you,
um,
it's going to work for you in long haul.
His stance is,
oh,
well,
I don't see it that way.
I don't see my mother as a problem,
but you do.
So let's try to figure this out so that you're not suffering because you're my
wife and I care about you.
That's,
that's where you're trying to go here.
Um,
so thank you so,
so much.
Thank you very much.
[inaudible].